Speaker 1: Matt Gates.
It's almost like every day there's a new scandal
facing beleaguered Republican Congressman
Matt Gates.
Earlier this week, we told you about his apparent
involvement in running a shill candidate in
Florida's 9th District.
I won't retell the entire story, but you can
check it out on our YouTube channel or the
podcast from earlier this week.
I think it was Monday or Tuesday where we
covered that.
We also know that he is being looked at for
involvement in child sex trafficking and a
whole bunch of other things.
The FBI or federal authorities, rather, seized
his iPhone some time ago.
It's looking really, really bad for Matt Gates.
Republican Congressman Steve Scalise, who
is a horrible person, says that.
Indeed, Matt Gates is charged, if there are
charges levied against him, that they would
take action and remove him from his committee
assignments if the Department of Justice files
charges, according to Newsweek, Scarless added
that historically, lawmakers who face charges
have been removed from committee assignments
immediately as a precedent.
This is the same.
This mirrors the House Republican rules that
lawmakers indicted for felonies and sentenced
to at least two years in prison must resign.
Now, the weird thing about sentenced to two
years in prison is their terms are only two
years long.
So that sort of seems a little strange that
you have to resign from committees.
But I guess you could be sentenced and get
a suspended sentence or something like that.
I don't know.
Scarless going on to say it's hard to speculate
on rumors, but if something really formal
happened from justice, we would, of course,
react and take action.
Scarless says he has not spoken with Matt
Gates and has not heard Matt Gates's explanation
for the allegations, but imagines he will
be speaking with him this week, saying, quote,
It's serious things alleged.
Obviously, we will want to get the facts.
Gates continues to deny the allegations, although
the denials often also include raising the
alarm with additional derogatory information.
For example, when he first went on Tucker
Carlson's show to deny some element of the
allegations.
He also said, I've never paid anyone for sex,
which at the time was not even part of what
we thought was going on.
Increasingly, it seems Matt Gates actually
has paid people for sex.
And whatever your thoughts are about paying
people for sex, the bone headedness of Matt
Gates raising new issues that weren't even
yet being looked at.
It's odd to say the least.
Gates did not go to a weekly meeting of House
Republicans yesterday, according to Steve
Scalise.
And it seems as though increasingly many Republicans
I mean, like it seems like Marjorie Taylor
Greene is sort of sticking with them.
She may go down with the ship.
It seems as though, you know, some of the
wackier members are sticking with Matt Gates,
but increasingly lots of people are abandoning
him.
It may indeed be a ship that simply goes down.
Now, as far as judiciary, there's a kind of
weird I don't know if I'd call it.
I guess it is a conflict of interest because
Matt Gates is currently on the Judiciary Committee.
The House Judiciary Committee has oversight
power over the very Department of Justice
that would be indicting Matt Gates.
It's not as though there's a very clear way
in which he's going to be able to do X or
Y as it relates to the investigation against
them.
But Steve Scalise saying, well, he'll he'll
have to resign from the committees if there
are charges.
And one of the committees he's on does oversight
of the entity that would be charging him.
That's you know, that that that's certainly
a question mark.
And then lastly, you know, Steve Scalise,
as I mentioned, is or is a horrible person.
He really can't be trusted.
So there's a question of whether they will
actually do it.
It's clearly in the House rules.
Scalise is saying Republicans would demand
that he do it.
I wouldn't be shocked if Gates does get charged.
And the House, controlled by Democrats based
on the rules, moves forward with stripping
Gates of his committee assignments.
I wouldn't be shocked if some Republicans
pulled out the allegations alone or not evidence.
And this isn't what should happen, even though
these are the House rules.
We'll wait and see.
I'm increasingly of the mindset that there's
probably some kind of charge coming against
Matt Gates, but without a doubt, he is innocent
until proven guilty and he is not yet even
been charged.
So we have to allow the investigations to
be carried out